foreign
if you were a Cadet who graduated from
the Air Force Academy yesterday things
were pretty weird even before Joe Biden
tried to break out into a little Trot
only to fall face first on the stage in
front of everybody
historically you know graduations have
been a time to congratulate students on
their achievements real or imagined and
to offer them advice as they embark on
their careers to that end it's customary
for commencement speakers to deliver a
message affirming the graduates
potential and their value to society and
so on you probably had to sit through
one of those speeches and all the
accompanying cliches and it could be
quite uh quite insufferable but that's
the way it goes presumably
um that was the kind of speech Cadets
were expecting to hear yesterday before
they got on with their lives but Joe
Biden delivered a very different kind of
speech it was so a historical so angry
and so bizarre that it's it's not crazy
to think that Joe Biden nose dived onto
the floor on purpose so that no one
would ever talk about what he actually
said
standing at the podium in front of
thousands of people Cadets their
families professors officers
Joe Biden explained that white people
make the Air Force weaker if I had to
explain that what makes the military
strong is not its battle Readiness its
skill it's training but rather it's
increasing lack of white people
and Men
that is of course what left is like
Biden always mean when they tout
diversity and that's the message that
Biden decided to send at his
commencement
and then having delivered that message
to all white Cadets in attendance
essentially Fu was the message
the president United States flew
headlong into the ground watch
your class
is one of the first most diverse
or any Academy to graduate that's why
we're strong that's why we're Who We Are
that's why we'll never give up that's
why a few moments later
[Applause]
[Music]
that's why we're strong he says before
collapsing to the ground
uh not exactly an expert on strength I
guess some of the cadets who had just
been forced to listen to Joe Biden's
speech seemed like they didn't want
anything to do with the whole situation
here's how one female Cadet responded
watch this
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
nope just walk slowly away
uh now it's kind of amusing uh but but
of course it's also it's also a sad
situation everyone recognizes this
and on top of that it's it's a major
problem for the entire country because
Joe Biden is the president
and he's running for reelection
if he somehow wins the election Joe
Biden will be 82 years old at the start
of the next term and we all know that
it's not breaking news the United that
the president United States is unfit to
serve
and by now you're probably familiar with
the spin on this incident from every
side you've probably seen all the
political takes you know CNN made a big
deal over that one time Trump tripped
but they're covering for Joe Biden for
example that sort of thing and that's
all true
but the real question is why is this
happening why is anyone still tolerating
this why would anyone even Democrats who
presumably want to field an electable
candidate in 2024 make excuses for Joe
Biden's obvious inability to serve as
the president United States
for some reason that's what they're
doing within an hour or two of Joe
Biden's fall NBC trotted out their fake
historian Michael bestclos and this is
the guy who who warned that your
children would be murdered in the
streets if Democrats lost the house and
midterms last year that didn't quite
materialize but the corporate media
tells you that best loss is still
someone that you're supposed to take
seriously and trust and yesterday he
wanted you to know that actually it's
normal for presidents to fall over it
happens all the time he cited two
examples Jimmy Carter was participating
in a race when he tripped and Gerald
Ford once fell down the stairs of Air
Force One
now doubters and haters might object and
point out that neither of those men fell
face first while trying to walk across a
flat surface
and neither man had difficulty speaking
coherent English during their terms
and by the way if you're keeping track
at home that's a significant problem for
Joe Biden that appears to be getting
worse here he was just a couple of weeks
ago attempting to use words to convey
some kind of idea listen
if they had to pay out 150 159
000 billion dollars LED
less for prescription drugs
then it reduces the deficit
at the risk of impuning Michael best
gloss's impeccable credentials as a
Prudential historian when someone trips
during a foot race but they're otherwise
acting and speaking normally it's not a
big deal but when somebody routinely has
to give up on sentences
just like give up in despair in the
middle of a sentence
and look at his audience like in the
clip you just saw that's alarming
and then that same person falls over
while walking a couple of feet you know
when that happens you're not crazy for
wondering if maybe this guy shouldn't be
president for the record this is Joe
Biden's second fall in a year you might
remember this incident while Biden was
cycling in Delaware let's watch that
again
[Applause]
all right
yeah yeah yeah keep up the good work I
keep on taking these things off you got
my split card
[Applause]
Mr President
and I'm ready to go
all right guys see ya
now Michael besklos and his colleagues
at NBC understand that their job is to
distract you from what you can see is
clearly true
you know he just wants to protect the
leader of his party no matter how much
humiliation he brings upon his Network
his profession his family name the
former Biden White House communications
Chief Kate Bedingfield also has no shame
whatsoever in response to Biden's fault
she sarcastically said quote I know I
personally have never ever tripped over
anything a day in my life not once
we can go on but the point is not to
humiliate a couple of soulless political
operatives bigger point and not there's
anything wrong with humiliating them the
bigger point and the one that's truly
frightening even if it's never mentioned
is that this is how millions of
Americans think they truly see no
problem apparently with electing a frail
and incompetent candidate like Joe Biden
that's how John fetterman was elected
senator in Pennsylvania
the one reporter tried to cover the
extent of fetterman's mental decline was
dog pile by the rest of the media
fetterman's wife said she should be
fired
then when Federman was shamed into
debating his opponent he began by saying
good good night everybody if you
remember
he proceeded to ignore a question asking
him to explain his brand new position on
fracking which just happens to be the
single most important economic issue in
the state and yet and yet he won how
along the same lines how is Dianne
Feinstein still representing California
in the Senate
her aides are running the office they
have been for a while it's not much of a
secret
that's why Feinstein learned from the
media that she wasn't running in 2024.
she learned from them
her aides put out a statement without
even telling her are you tired of
waiting ages for your grill to heat up
now you can say goodbye to those tedious
moments of impatiently watching the
charcoal burn and say hello to instant
barbecue Perfection thanks to our new
friends at uh and they're very good
friends already because they gave me one
of these our friends at Grill Blazer
Grill Blazers Grill guns are designed to
do everything from expertly searing your
Meats to lighting charcoal grills wood
stoves outdoor fireplaces and just about
anything else you can think of with high
power fire to solve your problem Grill
Blazers offers two types of Grill guns
the grill gun basic is a high power
propane torch designed to Light charcoal
and wood grills and smoke and smokers
and burns up to 3 600 Degrees its 30
inch flame is for anything you need a
big bad torch to do and the sous vide
gun has a shorter Barrel which I believe
is what I have here
perfect for professional Culinary
Kitchen user uses from gently
caramelizing brulee or other sugar
fruits to rapidly searing steaks outside
on the grill using the grill gun may
result in extreme Grill Envy from your
neighbors and increase demands for
barbecue parties they handed this thing
to me and I was just informed that
this thing is this thing is ready to go
so if I think if I pull this trigger it
fire will shoot out and I was told not
to pull the trigger let's find out what
happened so we know what happens if you
grill if you use this in your kitchen
what if I grill that TV over there what
will happen we could find that out
together
I'm finding it very difficult to
exercise Trigger Discipline with this
thing like the the temptation just I
really just want to pull the trigger and
see what happens no no I'm being told no
the white hammy one that's loaded this
thing is ready you know like don't put
the tank the propane tank on it
anyway uh get your grill gun from Grill
Blazers today and let the grilling
Adventures begin visit grillblazer.com
Walsh and use promo code Walsh for 15
off your order that's
grillblazer.com
Walsh promo code Walsh for 15 off your
order
have you been thinking about going back
to school to finish your degree or are
you just starting your college Journey
but you have little time to be in person
with classes Grand Canyon University's
online programs are designed to make
earning your degree easy and accessible
no matter your age or stage in life
whether you're a busy professional
looking to advance your career or a
stay-at-home parent juggling family
responsibilities their online courses
give you the flexibility you need to
learn on your own terms Grand Canyon
University specializes in helping you
fit your bachelor's Master's or doctoral
degree into your busy day from
scholarships to customized scheduling
your graduation team led by your own GCU
counselor provides you with the personal
support you need to succeed
so why wait if you're ready to take your
education to the next level you need
Grand Canyon University find your
purpose at Grand Canyon University visit
gcu.edu that's gcu.edu
both Feinstein and fetterman are elected
representatives who through no personal
fault of their own really are incapable
of representing anyone in fetterman's
case he's brain damaged in Feinstein
Stein's case she's 89 years old and
senile
and yet they're in office
and there are many more examples like
this
how does that make sense
and what does it tell us about the state
of the country
for those of us who have kids and who
care about the future of the United
States in the long term these are not
trivial questions at some point someone
should think about the answers
so let's take a stab at
instead of of barking embarking on some
novel theory for once well we'll do what
what the activists demand that we do
this is pride month
and we're told to view everything
through that lens so let's do that for a
moment
and in this case it might actually help
bring some clarity because the the
fundamental idea behind pride month is
that people are Gods you know basic
unchangeable elements of your Humanity
are in fact not obstacles at all they
tell you you can change them at will you
can alter your biological sex just by
saying so you can you can even alter
your child's biological sex
just head to Target and Tuck their penis
away in an lgbtq swimsuit
no one can judge you either because who
can judge gods God's judge they aren't
judged
so once you join the cult and you accept
your status as a God you can parade
naked in front of children if you want
that's not pedophilia that's Pride we're
told
pride is incompatible with religious
societies because religious societies
reject the idea that people are Gods
that's why all these corporations that
change their social media bios to
include Pride colors never change their
bios in in Middle Eastern countries
say what you will about those countries
but they actually take religion
seriously they believe in God
corporations know that so they don't
bother trying to shove Pride down their
faces over there if they did they'd be
destroyed
but in a society that's seriously
adopted the principle that underlies
pride and we have
maybe it's not so surprising that
millions of Americans have no problem
with politicians who claim they can defy
another fundamental element of humanity
which is aging
people get old and die their brains
atrophy their bodies start to wither
at a certain point they need to go
that's always been true
and there was a point when we recognized
that George Washington decided to retire
at 64. even though it could have easily
sought a third term as this country's
first president he was tired and old and
he knew it he didn't deny his Humanity
he embraced it
now our leaders sincerely believe
biology doesn't limit themselves or
anyone at all whether it's children or
the elderly
and that's like the mainstream position
when Jill Biden insists that it's a good
idea for her husband to start a second
term at the age of 82. when he can't
speak or walk without falling over
we're told to just nod along
after all Joe Biden has assumed godhood
you know and gods don't have to retire
this is the fundamental motivation
behind electing senile brain damage
people to leaders yes partly this is a
reflection of a country that has simply
given up on itself it's a manifestation
of our societal apathy
but it's also a denial of mortality it's
a denial of another of the basic truths
of human life
and you hear this from people you hear
this even from from people who are not
fans of Joe Biden
you hear people on the right so there's
a lot of reasons not to like Biden but
his age has nothing to do with it
yeah there are a lot of reasons not to
elect him but his age is definitely one
of them
but we don't need to get to his age
because it's also just incompetent and
corrupt uh you know on all that
but even if that wasn't all true but
still say we can't elect this guy
because the age does matter
and just because you have a grandmother
who's still spry and with it at the age
of 87.
I got a grandmother she's a real
firecracker at 92.
uh yeah well mortality still applies to
her just like it does to all of us
so you can watch that clip of Joe Biden
falling at the Air Force Academy and you
could say butt Trump and you can watch
it and say uh but Jimmy Carter but
Gerald Ford Etc you can laugh at it you
can feel sorry for Joe Biden
but the one thing you're definitely not
supposed to do is notice the reason that
that clip exists all Joe Biden is in
office because of a lie that is so
pervasive and intoxicating that everyone
now seems to believe it from University
professors to presidents to Children you
know and the problem with with lies is
that they tend to mask very real
problems the more we delude ourselves
into thinking that the impossible is
reality that people are Gods the more
we're inviting consequences we can't
even comprehend and there will be many
consequences if this senile decaying old
man is allowed to serve as the president
United States for four more years which
is why I won't say that Joe Biden's
canceled because that would be redundant
at this point but rather the people who
would actually vote for him for this for
that
are today canceled if you'd like to see
what else I have to say you can access
my full show by going to dailywire.com
or by going to the Matt wall Show
Twitter page hope to see you there
Godspeed